[Musique]
écoute moi quand tu étais au pays de
gier n'a dit un jour le grand barca a
décidé de passer le petit monde du
palais 11 kg décidé de faire une grande
inspection de mongolie pour voir si tout
est bien nano mais cherchez pas grande
yaka
je vais chercher votre voiture que je
suis copain je vais passer les fictions
de maïak est mobile aussi bien chez moi
pour but bonomo des remparts du home aux
cartes ou langue doublement des
questions dit que tu côté-là d'ouvrir le
grand gars qu'un pass l'inspection du
palais l'infection du palais planta
probable il va découvrir tout le monde
dit qu'on allait tout emporter il fait
découvrir mon réfrigérateur et veulent
confisquer vote en faisait le grand gala
d'averses en avignon
je bosse moi de la plus grande e 38
saint jacques tryba boire toute ma vie
on craint ce volume or c'est bien m en
alliant bonjour la vigilance j'ai écrit
de mémoires
on était la nouvelle halle aux grains
yada pavle avait dedans du ballet
d'inspections chez bois mais c'est qu'il
va découvrir tout mon batteur joe
empester le grand lavage au père pendant
maintenant au titus gratte-moi la tête
je vais trouve unis d'un ne revient pas
traîné
voilà je trouve les sens interdits
l'intense un avis bien sûr je vais te
montrer je trace une barre comme ceux ci
est d'accord à venir ça veut dire
défense le passé c'est bien connu on
aurait compris madrelle qu'un et voici
au sens obligatoire est bien connu celui
ci cède à force de stationner c'est bien
connu
alors tu as compris titus qui les
accroche on peut parfois y est temps
qu'ils nous mettent grenelle qui en moi
g
bon non unique parce qu'à mosca alors
j'attends mes yeux comme mobile j'arrive
grand hyatt
j'arrive eux je suis copain je vais
passer l'inspection des touchers mosca
je veux tout voir
et alors nous donne du pas trop vite et
fait-elle survirage ne freine pas trop
fort oscar potter étaient des changes
inquiet redit grande yaka et s'interdit
dans mon palais c'est le code de la
route internationale nous devons le
respecter mais tu as raison
mosca les suppôts le respect au moscato
tourner à droite
impossible regattin champs sont
obligatoires
il faut aller à gauche à l'origine tutu
a tourné à gauche est possible regard
d'un virage à droite obligatoires
et arrêter tous ici mosca un possible
grand yaka le stationnement interdit
bon alors que du moins ma faute et eu
mon expulsion est terminée avec juin le
grand yaka plein gaz je suis triste 18
de mon expulsion
tout était bien organisé signalisés
canaliser et nous nous vend bien
tranquille sûrs et après après c'est une
autre histoire